hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream number 124
and even number therefore it couldn't
possibly be prime without being two who
are you
oh i am dr brett weinstein and you are
dr heather heing and dayton and we are
here at an odd moment in the week but
doing the job that we usually do which
is trying to unpack at least some of the
madness that's in the world and
introduce
some curious bits that might otherwise
escape your notice so anyway that is at
least the broad brush picture from 30
000 feet
now we will zoom into a picture at a
more reasonable altitude indeed
so we are as we mentioned last week
going to be coming at you
to you uh from some
various moments uh and maybe even places
in the next few weeks but before we
launch into a little bit of logistics
today we're going to be talking a little
bit about
the bahamas the bahamas and
the the biology and geology of the
bahamas which we were fortunate enough
to experience for the first time this
last week and also fortunate enough to
experience and unfortunate enough to
have to leave indeed yeah we were
almost hoping to fail those mandatory
code tests on the way back into the
country and be forced to stay except
that only one of our wonderful children
was with us so um that would have uh
that would have put rather a damper on
things i don't know if our marvelous
hosts would have loved that either they
they claimed to want it but i you know
it's hard to imagine actually
um we're going to talk about uh the mass
mandates being lifted uh actually on on
federal i think or maybe it was all
transportation but the federal mandate
on mask
on masks in at least air travel in the
u.s was lifted while we were gone so we
flew down a mask we flew back without
masks and talk a little bit about that
um
we're gonna talk a little bit about
what a couple things happening over in
the white house uh including some
uh some some disinformation
czars
disinformations are it just makes you
wonder where they're there for or
against
yeah and then if we have time um just a
couple of of tidbits from some some
scientific findings that are out this
week or i think this week or at least
reported on this week
that
you know you could probably
i challenge you i challenge any of you
to make them political but these are
these are a political scientific
findings that just can bring either joy
or or inspiration or curiosity and not
at all make you wonder
what planet you can move to because this
one is no longer making sense but
somehow they will be polarizing i i
i don't yet know how depending on the
the creature's mode of sexual
reproduction it will be an offense to
one camp or another whether it's the
binaries or the continuous or i don't
know somebody's going to be offended
somehow sure well that is
ah that is the coin of the realm i guess
at this point right the coin well i mean
you know
and even if it isn't the the
reproductive mode it could be the color
of the creature it could be supremely
white or not or something or orange god
forbid right if it's camouflaged it
could be appropriating a color
inappropriately from something else yeah
ecosystem appropriation exactly
wow
doing their work for them
that can't be good well you know i think
frankly they're often they whoever they
are here um are bad enough at their work
that we can just help them along a
little bit we can help them and i've
already feel good i have previously
ranted about biogeographical
appropriation and how those of us not
from the the new world shouldn't
shouldn't be eating
potatoes or tomatoes or quinoa or
peppers or
oh boy coffee i guess no coffee come
from here
yeah chocolate
um i have bad news right though yes sir
the term the new world yeah it now
refers to mars
nope
not going there you're not doing that
not going to mars either yup not too dry
too dry too dry red too dry although i
will say uh that i finally after a lot
of
receiving this recommendation from a lot
of people and one wonderful audience
member actually sent
us
or me i don't remember how it was
addressed uh the the three books of c.s
lewis's
space trilogy
and the first one takes place on mars
and i read it uh this last week and it
is fantastic and in this fantastical it
is fantastic in both meanings of the
term and in this fantastical rendering
uh that c.s lewis has of mars it is in
fact neither dry nor inhospitable nor
lifeless really quite quite quite a
wonderful book and i'm told that the
third book in the trilogy which i'm not
two yet uh has many many allegories for
our time so we will we'll come back to
you with with that once i get there i'm
reading a lot of other things at the
same time so it may be a while all right
logistics yes yes
okay
um amazing things just happened in front
of us but no one needs to panic yeah no
and we're not we're not tripping no no
okay we know of um so this is live
stream number 124 i'm just going to walk
down some of the upcoming schedule
because it's a little weird
and say as i said last week or whenever
we were here last week and a half ago
that hopefully soon
within a few months we're actually going
to have a new platform where you can go
and see the upcoming schedule and you
know other events potentially and you
know community happenings and such uh
but for now it's just us reporting out
here
and next wednesday is going to be oh oh
we are not going to do a q a today after
the after the live stream today and in
general those that happen on
non-saturdays we probably won't do q and
a's just because of the the vagaries of
scheduling so well we can't stop them
from having queues
but we will not be delivering the
corresponding a's the and a part is uh
is honestly i might infer them
they might yeah and and i'm sure some of
some of the a's will be excellent
and uh thought-provoking in and of
themselves prompting perhaps more cues
which is
which is the way it is right the queues
just keep on coming yeah
um okay so next wednesday may 4th we're
going to do our uh live stream number
125 in the middle of the day probably
around noon pacific no q a the following
saturday may 7th
then it's going to be a while because we
have some travel that is just going to
make it impossible for us to do another
one until may 26th thursday may 26th
but in that intervening time there will
hopefully be one or two solo hosted
guest episodes that are coming out uh
from from you brett that should be
really excellent and there's one or two
that are going to come out uh sooner
than that as well i'm thinking yes
there is also i will just say a
possibility of something alive happening
this weekend no promises but uh keep
your eye out if you're interested in
such a thing but having nothing to do
with me you won't be here no i mean
you'll be live but we're not gonna we're
not gonna zoom call you in that would be
a demotion from
you know being present right here in the
room all right
um so then uh we're gonna do a couple
thursday may 26 and then saturday may
28th and
uh then
for a couple of weeks continuing on with
our saturdays so just a weird schedule
um
for which we apologize but
there are opportunities some of which we
will talk about as as they have happened
that are getting in the way of normal
scheduling yeah
wait i thought you were going to say
something no i was just pointing out
that it can't be avoided that um you
know part of what we do here involves us
being involved elsewhere in the world
and when it happens we go and
yeah and frankly i mean it's just it's
it's such a relief
to feel things opening up even as there
is uh a sense of dread uh for those of
us who have no way to forget about it
and frankly it would be better if no one
could forget about the fact that we have
now in most of the west or at least
certainly in canada and still in the u.s
have um and i assume i actually don't
even know what's happening in australia
and new zealand at this point
effectively have a two-tiered society
now uh where uh those who can who can
prove their cleanliness and exaltedness
and closer to godness of having been
vaccinated against covid
uh get all of the
get all of the things that were
previously understood to be just
perks of being a human being
largely
and those of us who are you know closer
to
i don't even know what the base
existence of man
and and and filthy and presumably
uneducated and rather dim
don't don't get as many of those things
many of those perks and uh even worse
you and i haven't talked about this but
um it re-emerged in in my sphere at
least today
that
this question of
effectively um subordinating our
sovereignty to the world health
organization is actually rapidly on the
march and so in the future such
questions might not even be decided
domestically they might be decided by
some other authority which is uh if you
think about it quite terrifying indeed
it is especially when it's the who
especially when it's an organization
with such an appalling track record on
exactly this question just now so you
know if we can potentially be willing to
hand over sovereignty to an organization
that has just failed on exactly this
topic then what what aren't we willing
to hand over our sovereignty for how
badly would they have to perform in
order for us not to be willing to hand
over our sovereignty to them that's the
question because it really you know they
uh unfortunately that sounded to me like
a challenge yes well
unfortunately it may turn out that
indeed um okay so uh we do encourage you
logistics again we encourage you to read
our book hunter gatherer's guide to the
21st century and to join our patreons
where we have uh monthly conversations
available to patrons of various stripes
and colors and creeds
patrons yes i think so yeah there was
didn't that didn't that zebra show up
for you one time didn't talk much two
guys in a zebra suit but
you didn't tell me how that resolved
that that was what it turned out with
them taking off the zebra suit and
participating in the conversation anyway
not as interesting as it could have been
but i mean i guess how a zebra gets
access to currency i don't know exactly
pay for access to the okay
i guess they use stripe
yep
that wasn't great no but i was admission
was free sitting right there somebody
was gonna have to say that joke was not
gonna make itself that's for sure they
rarely do
they really do okay we are uh we are
live right now on youtube and odyssey
chat is happening on odyssey we will of
course be on um
spotify apple
uh podcasts all the usual places soon
soon thereafter we have some some
merchandise that's stored at
darkhorsepodcast.org
we have
my natural selections substance which
this week i wrote about some of the
biology and geology of the bahamas we'll
be talking about that some here today
and we have as has become
our
want
what is a want
and it's not a it's it's i think it's an
o w-o-n-t see now you're getting me into
the spelling where i have but okay
forget about the spelling oh
wait what is it
um it's a it's a predilection
a predilection i think yes i mean yes i
guess i wonder about the etymology but
i'm going to look both words up later no
i know i i think you're right i just uh
i guess i was wondering about the
history of the word
uh want with it with an eye as is our
want as is our wand
you don't think it doesn't oh
the word
is this art no i don't think so
have you and so can kenzak can the uh
can the audience hear you
not very well yeah okay so now we're
just talking at our producer in the
other room that's that's not very good
very competitive
and our only defense is that they are
actually coming from people indeed
um as
as is our want so zach after we read our
ads you can come back to us with our
uh with the answer on this um
shall we pay their end
we must pay the rent apparently um it is
want with an o
uh but we don't know the etymology so um
awesome and find out if it's related to
wanton that also has an o doesn't it no
but it's w-a-n-t-o and it's not no
but it's a whole
it's like brett weinstein with two t's
except the second t is in the second
word yeah yeah
i rather like that yeah yeah okay so we
have three sponsors this week we are
very grateful for our sponsors as those
who have uh who are regular viewers or
listeners know
we introduce our sponsors with a with a
sound and
it's the opposite of introduce
extra dues
[Laughter]
evict no we do not evict our sponsors we
close out talking
doing our ads with another sound and for
those watching there's always a green
border around when we are
reading our sponsored content and we do
not do ads for any products that we do
not actually vouch for um so we reject
more sponsors than than we accept uh so
you can be sure that if we are reading
ads for these uh for these guys
we are actually enthusiastic and without
further ado you're first aha i am uh
reading this having not looked it over
i'm working without annette who called
in sick for work today always yes i
don't know what it is with her but
okay our first sponsor this week is ned
a cbd company that stands out in a
highly saturated cbd market you can buy
cbd products in nearly every coffee shop
or grocery store but ned's blends stand
out this month
they are promoting their dream set
their sleep blend contains cbn a
powerful cannabinoid that promotes sleep
with 750 milligrams of usda certified
organic cbd from the purest single
source hemp flour extract and they've
added 24 percent more organic and wild
crafted botanicals than their original
formulation
ned has also created mellow magnesium a
powerful daily magnesium supplement with
amino acids
and trace minerals that propel memory
mood brain function stress response
nerve muscle health and sleep these two
products sleep blend and mellow
magnesium with an oomlot are products
specifically developed to optimize your
body for sleep and relaxation
you're doing great you're amazed that i
came up with the word um lot while
reading that i know that you are a bit
yeah i am yes i think you should be
uh all of ned's full spectrum hemp oil
extracted from usda certified organic
hemp plants grown by an independent
farmer named
jonathan in payonea colorado
and on their site ned shares third party
lab reports and information about their
farmers and extraction process
med's products are science-backed
nature-based solutions that offer an
alternative to prescription and
over-the-counter drugs they are
chock-full of premium cbd and
full-spectrum
uh and a full spectrum of active
cannabinoids terpenes flavonoids
trichomes and offer functional support
for stress inflammation balance and
sleep we encourage you to try ned's
dream set darkhorse listeners get
fifteen percent off with the code
darkhorse
go to helloned.com
darkhorse
uh or enter darkhorse at checkout that's
hello ned
a-t-l-l-o-n-e-d dot com slash dark horse
to get 15 off thank you ned for
sponsoring the show and offering our
listeners a natural remedy for some of
life's most common health issues
our second sponsor
this week is eight sleep a relatively
new sponsor for us and we are excited to
know about them and proud to have their
support
good sleep is a game changer
as we discussed in the sleep chapter of
hunter-gatherers guide intelligent life
that found its way to earth might be
surprised by a lot of what it found on
our planet but not by the fact of sleep
or dreams
sleep is necessary without good sleep we
are destined to be unhealthy and
unproductive
yet more than 30 of americans struggle
with sleep and frankly that number
sounds low to me and temperature is one
of the main reasons it's well known that
individuals and couples who sleep
together often have different optimal
sleep temperatures eight sleep allows
fine-tuned temperature regulation for
both people having a cool room and a
warm bed is a luxury that ate sleep
makes easy to obtain
the pod pro cover by 8 sleep is the most
advanced solution on the market for
thermal regulation you can add the cover
to any mattress so you don't need to get
a whole new mattress and start sleeping
as cool as 55 degrees fahrenheit or as
hot as 110
both of which sound
extreme and undesirable but you can go
there if you want to
the temperature of the cover will adjust
each side of the bed based on your sleep
stages biometrics and bedroom
temperature reacting dynamically to
create the optimal sleeping environment
eight sleep users fall asleep up to 32
faster reduce sleep interruptions by 40
and get more restful sleep overall and
with 30 more deep sleep on average that
restorative sleep will likely help with
physical recovery hormone regulation and
mental clarity
finally the alarm feature which can wake
you with temperature change and or
slight chest level vibrations is so much
gentler than any standard alarm we are
both a little skeptical and are now
totally sold we are surprised at how
much we appreciate this bed
go to 8sleep.com darkhorse to check out
the pod pro cover and save 150 at
checkout eight sleep ships to the u.s
canada and the uk
i'm going to argue that they should stop
calling it an alarm feature that alarm
is the bad thing we're trying to avoid
waking up by being alarmed as bad it
should be the wake up feature the rouse
feature i'm not actually sure
that they call it the alarm feature they
may well we should stop calling it the
alarm feature because the wake up
feature yeah the wake up feature yeah
and our final sponsor this week is mike
m-o-i-n-k
97 of the chickens served in the u.s are
dipped in chlorine
this is because big ag doesn't have the
same quality standards as the family
farm an eighth generation farmer founded
moic that's moo plus oink so you can
help save the family farm and get access
to the highest quality meat on earth
moick delivers grass-fed and
grass-finished beef and lamb pastured
pork and chicken and wild-caught alaskan
salmon direct to your door
moik farmers farm like our grandparents
did and as a result moink meat tastes
like it should which is to say delicious
unlike the supermarket mike gives you
total control over the quality and
source of your food you choose the meat
delivered in every box like rib eyes
chicken breast pork chops to salmon
fillets and much more and you can cancel
any time
i love everything about mike the fact
that the meat is grass-fed and finished
on small farms the lovely publications
that come along with it and of course
the meat itself
shark tank host kevin o'leary called
moiq's bacon the best bacon he's ever
tasted i agree it's amazing
keep american farming going by signing
up at mointbox.com darkhorse right now
and listeners of this show receive free
filet mignon for a year
that's one year of the best filet mignon
you'll ever taste but for a limited time
spelled m-o-i-n-k box dot com
chlorine
apparently that's insane yeah
there is a problem with what they're
trying to do and it would involve using
alcohol
anyway we digress indeed
um well and actually i mean that's not
too far afield from talking about it's
going to sound very far afield from
talking about the bahamas but um not but
not necessarily with regard to
uh the
you know the amazing
beauty and function in the world and how
it is that we have responded to
fast growth and high population density
with choices that are unnecessarily
damaging you know we we we have real
real limits that we are coming up
against with regard to
habitat degradation and destruction and
places where the population is just too
dense um to live as healthily as as we
would want but there are almost always
at least better solutions than the ones
that we are engaging in
and and you are bringing one of these up
by suggesting um
that you know for for the vast majority
of chickens that are not raised with
colin integrity
and and
more traditional
traditional methods um at least an
alcohol dip rather than a chlorine dip
might do the trick i actually i don't
know and i don't know what else that
would do to change the the meat texture
flavor lastingness any of it but it's at
least
well i mean i think i think this is
biologically fairly clear and i have no
doubt that alcohol would be
more expensive and would require tending
because of course the alcohol well
chlorine might evaporate out too but um
but this strikes me as a mirror for one
of the most horrifying stories of
industrial development that i've ever
encountered which my grandfather
introduced me to um i don't know i was
probably still in high school
and it was a story of tetraethyl lead
and how it ended up in gasoline which is
a real jaw-dropper
right and the
the long and short of it is there was a
perfectly viable alternative that wasn't
patentable
and so they patented tetra at the lead
and its function in gasoline was to
prevent knocking and pinging and
knocking and pinging are basically
explosions that are out of place and so
end up over time distorting the engine
they basically release energy at a
inappropriate moment in the compression
stroke and
um that is destructive of the engine so
none of us should want knocking and
pinging you know it uh it is an actual
indicator of something that is
potentially doing damage to doing damage
to the vehicle and is therefore
environmentally bad because it means
that the engine and maybe the whole
vehicle will have to be replaced sooner
so it is an honest-to-goodness problem
but tetra-ethelet is an appalling
solution to it because you know the
toxin in tetraethyl lead is lead it's an
element it doesn't go anywhere in this
combustion process and so effectively
into the air where we breathe it in and
become dimmer as a result right and you
know in places like los angeles where
cars were everywhere and the mountains
are shaped just so it's not like it
blows away so it accumulates in the
atmosphere and there's a credible line
of thought that suggests that this has a
lot to do with the crime waves that we
may have
seen at various periods of history and
the fact that no one of any intelligence
was produced in los angeles in the 1970s
something like that
we barely avoided that one but uh
but yeah it's a it's an appalling
appalling story and it involves all
kinds of things like the delusions of
the people who were um
uh advancing this terrible solution who
went to you know demonstrate
that it was safe and there are terrible
stories of people dying on the factory
floor from mere contact with the stuff
yeah it's it's an awful story but anyway
the point is
you have various kinds of solutions and
then you have a series of perverse
incentives you know
if alcohol is more expensive
than uh than bleach you know do we
expect them to use it well not unless
you force it and from a health
perspective if the harm that comes to
you from eating chickens that have been
you know dipped in bleach
uh is delayed then how the hell are you
ever going to know that the tumor you
had or the decrease in your iq or
whatever might befall you from that
bleach is your stand-in for chlorine
here that's you're saying bleach yeah
yeah yeah um
so in any case uh
the point is
the system is built so that you'll never
catch up to the people who made this
terrible decision on your behalf in fact
i only learned today that anybody had
made a decision like this on my behalf
and uh
anyway we need to get better at this
yes we do
um the bahamas we were talking about
that
yeah uh i you know i i don't have a plan
so much i think you have some
photographs um that you would like to
share but maybe just um so i will i will
link to my the piece that i that i wrote
um on the way back from the bahamas so
we have
we have friends both
skillful and generous who invited us
down um to spend six nights on their
boat where they are um
where they have been and they're
actually headed back home to florida now
um
for two months or so um our friend dave
stevens was able to do his work remotely
uh which is you know
one of one of the things about modernity
which is really quite remarkable and of
course we also saw and you know got
introduced to a little bit of the
navigation that he was using
um so they were he and madeline his wife
uh were
were cruising in and they invited us to
be with them and we went down with our
16 year old son toby
in the exumas an island chain in the
bahamas that i'd never heard of before
before they invited us and it's right on
the edge of a vast like hundreds of
square miles and i actually couldn't
totally figure out how big i think it
may be well over a thousand square miles
of incredibly shallow water like never
goes below 30 feet deep and is often
less than 10 feet deep and of course
that's going to change somewhat with the
tides but that means that no boats with
a deep draft can can explore these
waters at all and so you have
you have some very very nice boats of
course but all with um shallow drafts
you don't it's not you know there's no
cargo boats there's no shipping lanes uh
and for the most part you don't have um
you know
speed boats and other things that you
may have come to associate with you know
really gorgeous caribbean
water you know seascapes and landscapes
and so this
this was in many ways a revelation being
being down in this place and the the
first night that we were out
uh we spent on anchor off of shroud key
and uh the shroud key has no marina no
um no no buoys even i i think um so you
just you have to be skillful enough to
get there
um to know to know the weather enough
and know the tides enough and the and
the and the soundings i guess is the is
the word for the depths um and to to put
your anchor down safely and
from there you can um you know dive in
right off the boat and snorkel or take a
skiff in through these
uh through these
creeks
they're yeah they're not really creeks
they're informally called creeks but
they're basically cracks in these
limestone uh outcroppings in which the
salt water flows through exactly exactly
and they are shroud key in particular is
just lined with mangroves and when we
heard when i heard madeline talking
about the mangroves in advance
i imagine the mangroves i have known and
mangroves mangrove is not a lineage like
mangrove is a strategy that has evolved
actually apparently more than 30 times a
strategy for i'm a plant i find myself
in this really marginal place where most
of the water that i have access to is
salt water and even if i can pull water
in somehow from the rain that falls from
the sky my roots are still soaked in
salt water what am i going to do
and so there are a lot of different
evolutions of the mangrove strategy and
i've been i have been in a lot of them
as have you we've been in mangrove
madagascar in panama i've been in
mangrove in mexico
in costa rica i feel like other places
in honduras
um
a lot of places
they're always
kind of tall
and these mangroves are incredibly short
and dense
and
presumably this is because of the winds
that are coming that occasionally come
off the atlantic in the form of
hurricanes and you know lesser winds as
well uh but you can you can take a take
a small skiff through these through
these creeks which are actually title
tidal flow and
see
green sea turtles
and
sharks both nurse sharks and i think we
saw another species but we saw it
briefly enough i'm not totally sure
rays
fair number of fish although um the
inside the channels there you don't
really have coral so it's not the
abundance of reef fish that we saw um
elsewhere on on the coral reefs
and
it's just an abundance of diversity that
is extraordinary
and also when you go someplace else and
around coral reefs
you find
the the number of strategies the number
of again lineages of just fish just fish
we're talking about for the moment
that have
learned how to make a living off a reef
and who do things like specialize on
cleaning the insides of other fish's
gills
or mouths
and there are some scientists still who
are saying yeah i'm not so sure it's
exactly the kind of symbiosis that we're
thinking sometimes those bigger fish do
in fact eat the smaller fish
but they're really and they're also some
cleaner shrimp dedicated cleaner shrimp
so there's that there are these beau
gregories which are these as juveniles
they're bright blue and yellow who hang
out in abandoned conch shells live in
abandoned cog shells there are a number
of fish who are
sequential hermaphrodites we were
observing parrotfish for instance which
are protogenous hermaphrodites which
means proto-first
gin giant uh female so they start out as
females and then some of them if the
male dies the dominant female will turn
into a male and um in every way
both her sex she will start she will
move from producing eggs to producing
sperm everything about her will change
into a hymn
both anatomically and physiologically
and also behaviorally the sex role the
gender if you will
uh and there are other there are other
lineages that are hermaphroditic as well
and then
the thing i learned about parrotfish on
this trip not from watching but from
watching observing us talking and then
looking in i didn't bring it here um
this fabulous field guide that i brought
along with me which is reef fish
behavior for um
uh florida
bahamas and the caribbean i think is
what it's called
they claim and i actually did seek out a
paper
suggesting that this is this is a claim
that is legitimate that
much
of the sand
on caribbean
reefs and beaches
came out the back end of a parrotfish
yeah that parrotfish have these modified
teeth that they've turned into beaks
they're very hard
and they rasp algae off of dead coral
and depending on the species and the
mood of the parrotfish they just bang
their heads in the dead coral and some
of them are neater than others but none
of them are particularly neat and they
end up just taking a huge amount of
coral skeleton
and
apparently something like 75 of the gut
content of parrotfish is inorganic
material and they've got specialized
anatomical and physiological structures
that grind the stuff down and basically
if you follow a parrotfish you're
releasing a constant plume of this coral
that has now been grounded to tiny bits
which is what we call sand
yeah and
my experience up until this trip was
that on anything that uh you would call
a coral reef the sound of parrotfish
chomping is almost constant and yeah
it's constant snapping and it was
actually kind of rare on this trip and
i'm not sure what to make of it because
of course we'd never been to this place
before so i don't know if the amount of
it has dropped or this particular
location which has obviously a huge
amount of sand associated with it yeah
um you know is just
low in relative density of parrotfish
you know we did see a few but not many
um so anyway it sort of left me
wondering i mean clearly given the
amount the volume of sand that we're
talking about we're talking about
hundreds of thousands probably millions
of years of accumulated uh parrotfish
droppings are the fine sand on these
beautiful caribbean beaches yes which is
a really cool fact it's amazing
but uh yeah it was it was interesting um
i i must say
one thing that i got out of this little
adventure that i had not gotten from any
previous one in general you and i have
sought out
you know the great snorkeling wherever
we go right
and the great snorkeling not in the
amazon so much right
but uh it tends to be you know a big
reef and it's sort of the classic you
know you drop off the boat or whatever
it is and there you are and there's this
giant accumulation of coral heads and a
huge number of fish and all of that and
in this case
snorkeling did not seem to be what the
people who were there were doing in any
significant numbers in fact we were
really
the people doing the snorkeling enough
that other people we spoke to were sort
of curious about what we were seeing and
where to go and all of that and so what
it did was it revealed what i think is
the much more normal distribution of
these reefs which is a coral head here a
coral head there large expanse of sand
between them and sea grass yeah so in
any case it gave but the biologist in me
was very excited to get good at figuring
out where to go look for the reef fish
rather than just be dropped to the place
where they're everywhere and you know
yeah it was less like a nature
documentary it was less like it had
already been curated or disney fied or
whatever and that's not to say that some
of the other experiences we have had
haven't been extraordinary well they've
been great um but having having to work
for it a bit right and having to swim
for it and like sometimes swim a fair
ways uh is there's also a lot of reward
and just like okay at some point i'm
gonna turn around because i've gone a
while and there's just nothing but you
know sand and sea grass and and oh whoa
wait like there's a there's a slope now
and here we go like here here we
happened upon another
thriving area of diversity after a long
expanse of of sea grass yeah it's
actually it's its own kind of training
program for your mind how well do you
understand what these creatures are
doing enough that you can look at a
landscape and say i bet if i go over
there i'll see it and then sometimes
you're right and sometimes you're wrong
and your model gets better but it's a
little bit like
when we take people into you know uh an
intact tropical rainforest
and you know everybody's experience is
the same when they walk into such a
thing which is
where are the critters right i see it
where's all the fighting and the sex and
the exuberance what i see is a wall of
green i can make no sense of and the
point is you you do learn to make sense
of it but you learn to make sense of it
in some ways that you don't expect you
know how do you find monkeys
with your ears you almost always hear
them before you see them right and how
do you find peccaries with your nose
you smell them before you see them or
hear them right and then you uh think
carefully about whether you want to come
and where to stand right exactly
not so much on reefs i i've rarely run
into peccary's unreal yes
for some reason we did not
occur to me near it but uh for some
reason somebody has pigs that tourists
go to swim with in the bahamas and the
exumas i i don't care yeah that was uh
we actually passed it on one of our yeah
one of our forays actually to get our
final cover test to be allowed to come
back into the u.s i don't get it i don't
get it either and it's domestic pigs
whatever it is it's not kosher that's my
feeling um
but
anyway so i was enjoying the learning
how
coral reef actually works rather than
being dropped into the overwhelming
experience and getting a very wrong idea
i think for what the majority of these
you know fish and other creatures are
yeah do you want to show a few yeah why
don't we show a few things and you know
i i i now realize after all the things
you said i picked many of the wrong
images and videos hey zach you want to
put up the uh
all right well let's try how about the
image of the tropic bird
so this is a tropic bird and so as we
arrived at um
at shroud key our first mooring there
were a group of these tropic birds and
brett is not miss speaking this is if
this is also a tropical bird we were
actually just outside of the tropics we
were about 24 and a half degrees north
and the tropic line is at 23 and a half
um but we were in you know this is a
subtropical bird um but it's called a
tremendous individual is hanging out
just barely in the subtropics but anyway
it's a tropic bird these are
uh squid specialists this is one of
three species of tropic birds wait what
the squid specialist i didn't know that
yeah isn't that amazing i hope i'm
speaking correctly about this species
but in any case the cool thing about
this this demonstrated it's crazy yeah
it's wild
so
heather you and i and our family ran
into tropic birds the first time
on
uh de la plata in ecuador
where some guides
um
offered us a choice that we could not
make heads or tails of where there were
some nasca boobies on one part of this
island
and there were uh
what they called tropical birds tropical
birds and they asked you want to see the
trouble we wanted to see the the nazca
boobies or the tropical basketball is
being also tropical birds right for
those every bird that is there
so we couldn't figure out what they were
talking about but they seemed like the
more exotic interesting thing would be
the tropical birds so we followed them
to see the tropical birds and it turned
out it was tropic birds which we had
never seen before
now i think i believe i have only seen
tropic birds twice once in on that
excursion and then here as we pulled in
to uh to
shroud key there were a number of them
vocally uh interacting and chasing each
other and it was very dramatic and i
immediately you know
i have learned painfully as a
photographer that if you arrive
someplace and suddenly you see some
creature and you think wow while i'm
here i'm going to get pictures of those
you may not see them again right and so
anyway i took the camera out and i
started trying to capture it so that at
least i wouldn't you know walk away
without anything yeah and uh anyway it's
a beautiful i think believe this is a
female the males have an even longer
train yes which raises really
interesting questions about what the
sexual selection regime is that both the
males and females are ornamented with
this long train but the males are longer
so anyway there it is um
let's see next photograph yeah you could
also just have him pop up since you gave
our amazing producer
so these photographs i haven't been
through them i haven't corrected them
this one obviously could use a little
correction with these
some turns that photographs are
beautiful sorry for those of you just
listening yeah you're just listening but
anyway here we have a pair of uh of
turns on a on a piling
um one of them descending and landing
next to the other actually i got the
whole sequence of the landing and it was
pretty comical but yeah it wasn't the
most graceful landing i've seen they're
kind of comical birds yeah they're
pretty nice though it's like a it's like
a fancy goal yeah um totally all right
now zach can can you show and i think um
i think the turns are sister to the
gulls i think i'm pretty sure they're
very close
i agree
okay one video not this one stop that
that's one
last
uh just no except that that one has to
be last
so i will say well here we go
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
living for themselves
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
stay there
[Music]
so
this is
there was a
um
effectively an academic era they are um
but also it was elaborate it was a lab
leak it was um so apparently with the
help of a hurricane uh a colony that was
being studied um
i had some escapees and they're now all
over the caribbean and there it was it
was
you know when i cast aspersions here but
university of florida gainesville or
something right that happened i don't
know who it was so i'm gonna i'm gonna
hold off with that but but somewhere in
florida
had a colony that they were studying for
some reason that and we we didn't we
have not pursued this story beyond what
nancy told us um but then a hurricane
breached the reached the columns and you
know this is this is one of these
terrible things that people do not
intuit which is
there are some creatures that if they
get out they don't survive there are
other creatures that'll survive but they
don't invade and then there's this third
kind of creature that is so well adapted
to the habitat that they find themselves
in that they actually out compete the
local fauna and there's no it's not
always fauna but there is no
good way of dealing with it and the
number of stories where something has
gotten out where it shouldn't and uh has
effectively
naturalized and then somebody has
introduced some other thing to try to
get rid of it you know
mongeese and mongooses in hawaii and
jamaica things like this and it just
never works right for biological reasons
they you know predator and praise cycle
or whatever but anyway the point is this
um
every time we now travel to one of these
amazing places
it is
both glorious
and
an absolute tragedy right and this trip
had this sort of bittersweet aspect to
it not only the lionfish of which we
only saw one which is pretty good
um but there was also this thing which
we have now seen in so many places
especially in the caribbean
which is every
one of these absolutely spectacular
beaches at least on the ocean side every
single one of them is just
filled with things that have washed up
out of the ocean right and we're talking
about you know plastic carboys uh
flip-flops i saw medical waste
and at some level
you know i think
a it's interesting the people who go to
these places including us
have the reaction of like oh my goodness
i tell you what i'll bring a trash bag
will will at least do something right
and it's it's pointless right the amount
of material washing out of the ocean is
so great that there's just no making a
dent but you know everybody has this
reaction of like oh my god i can't
believe at least let me do something
right i'm looking at one of the most
beautiful vistas i've ever seen and it's
compromised if i you know i in order to
take a picture that i want to look at
again i'm going to have to
place myself very carefully you know
there's a tire there you know
whatever it may be and so
this is just a classic externality right
this is an externality of the way we
live we have chosen materials that are
cheap we have chosen to dispose of them
in ways that result in them not being
captured and dealt with appropriately
some of these materials are not
permanent they will break apart the
plastics are all breaking apart in the
sun but unfortunately we now know
what they break apart into is
microscopic dust which gets into all of
our uh lungs and
into the all of the animals and you know
things are differentially tolerant of it
but it's a tragedy we are effectively
wrecking the planet and you know
because we'd never been to the bahamas
before we are in no position to compare
it to how it was and this is this is one
of the questions we were asking each
other right what did
what did this place look like 100 years
ago right and we don't know we don't
know and i don't know
i don't know if that has been recorded
presumably it has somewhat but but
the problem is that where we are in a
position to compare even over relatively
short time spans
there is often a horror story hidden
right and so you know let's take the
trash example
most of the places that we go are now
compromised in this way but you and i
know a few places where this isn't true
right
in the amazon at tippetini for example
it is
very rare that you encounter anything i
i believe the most prominent example of
trash that had come in from the outside
world is a piece of dimensional lumber
that had lodged in the river right
that's pretty mild at that point yeah
you don't uh upstream uh you know the
source of the rivers in the andes is not
generating
trash that is at least that's making it
down too right it's getting stuck so the
rio tippetini or the rear shear puno or
the novel
so on the one hand from the point of
view of visual indicators it seems
more like it's untouched
on the other hand over the period of
time you and i have been going there
which is
you know at this point nine years nine
years not quite a decade
we have seen
certain kinds of animal life
disappear and inexplicably in some cases
it used to be
that you could go out at night and you
could reliably find cayman in the
tippatini river right and there's a
trick you use a headlamp it's mounted on
your head the animals look at you
because you're emitting light and you
can see the shine from their eyes and it
was like
it was relatively easy to find cayman
you could probably find
uh 20 in an hour uh of boating
didn't see one last time
that's pretty amazing
that the uh
i didn't see any i was looking for him
um and i was looking for you know in
part i was looking for them as a
photographer looking for you know i'd
learned from the photographs i'd taken
last time and i wanted a
a a redo right i wanted a rematch
and
just didn't see it right that's amazing
to see a spectacular it's not like we
saw half as many and we were wondering
and that's not a that's not a species
that we would think of as being
particularly fragile right why should it
be yeah right it's a crocodilian right
small crocodilian it's a small
crocodilian it's pretty robust it's not
going to be highly sensitive to slight
changes in temperature of the river
probably what it means is that the
things that it eats in the river which
are very likely to be fish have crashed
right and that we don't see that because
the river is muddy we can't see the fish
but we can see the
the cayman yeah the muddy the muddy the
the rio tippatini
which is a tributary of a tributary
tributary of the amazon
is what's called a white water river
in in the amazon basin of which there
are white water rivers and black water
rivers so white water doesn't mean the
same thing as like you know having a lot
of rapids white water refers to the
amount of silt
which is coming basically off of glacial
melt and so
the the water is not clear it is the
opposite of the water in the bahamas in
fact and then black water rivers
are very dark
from the tannins released by um by leaf
fall
from from plants and in fact
neither here nor there but uh where the
rio negro and the rio amazon come
together and
um and then we name we name rivers i
don't actually know that there's an
established
uh
way that they get named i assume it's
like whatever seems bigger or more
important but anyway once they come
together then the negro just gets um
assimilated into the amazon but they
literally run side by side for a while
and i was lucky enough to be there um in
gosh 2003 i guess
um and the rio negro is as you would
expect from the name of black water
river the amazon the amazon is a white
water river and they literally for like
a couple of miles in manaus uh the city
in brazil where uh where this happens
where the confluence of the negro and
the amazon happen
they just run side by side there's
nothing separating them but water
chemistry and temperature and then at
some point you realize oh it's now it's
now just all one color but it's
extraordinary aqueous apartheid
i guess
to put an absolutely obnoxious spin on
it
um
but okay so
the fact is
almost anywhere we go if we do have any
sort of a time series
we get the same story which is things
are not going in a good direction they
are going so wrong so quickly that even
you know it doesn't take a human
lifespan to see the decline it takes
less than a decade in many of these
places and this happens
uh on so many different fronts now i
have to say
the thing one always has to be careful
about if you're scientifically minded
and if you just simply want to know what
the
what's happening in the world is you've
got to correct for the fact that it may
be that you've heard horror stories
about the world coming apart and so
you're sensitive to the stuff that you
can no longer find where you were but
you're not sensitive to the stuff you
can find there now that wasn't there to
begin with
right and so the idea is yeah there's
ebb and flow and maybe maybe what you're
really seeing is dynamism and you're
just sensitive to the stuff that seems
like it's gone like loss aversion is
causing you to mis assess
and there are some stories you know when
we were kids
bald eagle that was like a mythical
creature right right
now we didn't live in a place in
southern california bald eagles would
would not have been common i don't think
they would have been present at all um
however
they wouldn't have been common up north
either and now we see them all the time
they're really common yeah i mean it we
know where a few areas are just right
here within a couple miles of our home
in portland yeah if you're sensitive to
them so that you know you're assessing
every bird that flies over if you can
figure out what it is and you're looking
for them you'll see bald eagles it's
relatively common um and that is a
direct result of our intervention right
on their behalf and there are many
stories like that um
northern elephant seals were nearly
extinct they are now what did we do for
them
um
well we protected their
rookery and i must be a hunting story
involved there it might actually just
really be the the beach the rookery the
beach yeah um
otters
otters actually otters are sea otters
you're talking about i'm talking about
sea otters sea otters were hunted i
think the population was below 80. yeah
in the world right left pacific sea
otter
and it rebounded beautifully and now
it's on the decline again is it yeah oh
very much so we've gotten much harder to
see
um so anyway these stories you know
there are some positive stories there's
some mixed stories but in general the
stories are all negative and the degree
to which
when you and i started traveling to you
know the yucatan for example the degree
to which you could go to a beach and it
wasn't just covered in flotsam and
jetsam you know it's not that there was
nothing
right but uh
it has changed dramatically the oceans
were noticeably cleaner and you could
tell that by uh what was flung up out of
them on to the coasts right and if you
think about the puzzle that this
represents like let's say you know a and
that would have been that's 30 years ago
that's when we started traveling
so
i would argue
people have a right
right that it's hard to define how the
right works
but it's nobody's right to rob other
people of the ability to emerge onto a
beach and have it be natural right it's
not your right to throw stuff into the
sea somewhere that destroys somebody
else's beach and even people who live in
these places
they don't get the benefit of having
their own coastline you know they may be
impoverished and the one
glory of their existence is that they
happen to live in a beautiful place and
the point is even that will be robbed uh
from them it's it's it's a tragic state
of affairs but if you think about what
you would have to do if you just
recognized yeah actually we don't have
the right to do that
to anybody's beaches
that means we have an obligation to
control this stuff
right well then how would you even solve
that because the question is you would
have to be really good at capturing this
stuff everywhere right at the point that
it was no longer useful it would have to
be captured and
um the problem is that would jack the
price up and so the point is it's far
easier to ignore it and some and some
products shouldn't be allowed just as uh
the uh the increase in bald eagles and
other raptors it is largely attributable
to the
um to the regulation around ddt yeah
right but because ddt is now understood
to thin eggshells and birds at the top
of the bird food chain are likely to get
the most of it and so bioaccumulate it
there are likely to be other products
not chemical in nature but you know
physical plastics and such some kinds of
products that actually shouldn't be made
oh
many many products that shouldn't be
made and many products that should be
made out of something else and many
products that should have a built-in
cycle so that it's made but it is
recaptured right there are a lot of ways
to address this but the problem is
people cannot wrap their mind
out of if you take as a given we don't
have the right to lose control of these
things and have them emerge on somebody
else's beach
right then you have to construct the
world differently and nobody's up for
that level of regulation and so it
doesn't end up happening which means
that we're just living one giant tragedy
of the commons but even worse
if you think about
most people are not lucky enough to have
the
kind of access to these remote places
that we've had yes
when people get access very often they
get access in the context of you know
well i'd like to go to mexico and you
know
here's a here's a resort right and the
point is the resort will of course for
its own selfish reasons
hire local people for presumably too
little money to keep the beaches clean
of this stuff which will falsely give
the impression that this is a beautiful
tropical beach and not that it is an
exceptional
beach
that's the result of high vigilance etc
and so people people get the wrong
impression and then because everybody
wants to take nobody wants to i mean you
know look i'm a photographer i was
thinking about the trash this whole trip
and i was thinking i should be
documenting this and there was a part of
me that just couldn't bring myself to do
it right i couldn't make myself do it i
didn't want to accept that it was that
real and so i don't have those pictures
right even though i i felt obligated to
take them i just i didn't live up to my
obligation
there's something very important here
and this is this is a theme that we
should come back to uh but something
that
i i think you too but i certainly used
to always spend time in my teaching on
around the concert of ecotourism where
ecotourism appeals to people who think
that they care about nature and the
environment and are making green
decisions
and
i ended up
quite by accident sort of in deep with
some ecotourism politics as a result of
my very first field research
where
you know this story but um i was we were
we were in costa rica with four other
graduate students and our professor for
the summer and he was basically doing a
field course for us for the first five
or six weeks and then we were
to do our first research before
presenting that as part of our
qualifying exams to get to the next
stage in graduate school
and i went down to costa rica with a
hypothesis that i generated in
madagascar around
monkeys preferring
uh fruit trees that have been cultivated
and planted by humans to the wild fruits
because monkeys would have similar
versions to secondary compounds as we do
i pretty i was pretty pleased with it i
generated by watching
what crown lemurs in madagascar prefer
tamarind uh which is an import from
india
to all of the local trees
and
i we were at this little tiny field
station in sarapiki not last eleven the
big one but a little tiny one called
silva verde
silverade
oh solo verde was the name of the
ecotourist lodge yeah uh it was called
el buhuco meaning vine right or lyanna
anyway um we were at this field station
which is where we had decided that we
would be doing our research and i just
couldn't find the monkeys couldn't find
the monkeys at all
they weren't there and i go out you know
every morning
you know with dawn and at dawn
don wasn't with us at the time uh at
dawn also called in sick for work
also called in sick for couldn't take
the humidity
and um was out there for many hours
every day slowing through the mud
and
never found the monkeys they were just
m.i.a but what i did happen upon were
some poison dart frogs which was my
introduction to them i had no previous
experience with them so it's called dark
poison frogs and
it included a species that wasn't
supposed to be there
that i didn't know that at first but i
started talking to you know you and the
other graduate students and our
professor and it became clear like
there's this one species i'm seeing uh
what was then called dandridge's oratus
it's still a radius which is a big black
and green job uh which is you know much
larger than the native pomego a little
blue jeans frog with bright blue legs
and a red back and sort of
some dark dark um arms
uh eratis as it turns out
had been introduced by this local
ecotourist lodge
why why would a place that is trying to
attract tourists mostly gringos from the
us to come and supposedly enjoy intact
undisturbed
lowland tropical rainforest also known
as jungle in costa rica why would they
introduce a species of frog and they
didn't introduce it from very far away
they introduced it from i think the
creeping coast of nicaragua if memory
serves
but it was bigger it was brighter a
little easier to see than the native
congener than the native close relative
and you bring in a bigger
version of the organism that's already
there and maybe it would work out in
this case it didn't though and so my
very first research ended up being
documenting the way in which auratus the
introduced by supposed ecotourist lodge
species was actually driving extinct
locally extinct pamela the blue jeans
frog and you know for why for why who
you know who who wins as a result of
that a few american tourists presumably
who had no idea what had been done on
their behalf presumably wouldn't have
signed off for it off on it if they had
known
got access to another photo
opportunities they might not have had
and saw a frog in a place that it had no
business being and that frog was
responsible for driving a local species
extinct
okay let's be let's be a little bit um
let's be fair about this
there's a lot of stuff so i agree with
you it's it's a tragedy that a radius
was introduced in sarapaki
um
for one thing we know exactly what it is
that it drives out right it's a direct
competitor for pomeglio and um
that makes it an obvious tragedy
if we take the situation on san juan
island
on san juan island uh san juan island
has
a couple of hazards to navigation that
have lighthouses on them back before
these were inhabited islands the
lighthouse keeper needed to tend the
lighthouse in order that ships didn't
get wrecked in order to feed the
lighthouse keeper
rabbits were released this is a
brilliant strategy if you think about it
you release rabbits and you hunt them as
needed
um and the rabbit's got to stay fresh
that way
they do stay fresh that way
rabbits got out of control predictably
enough
so foxes were brought in right now the
foxes are
an utterly delightful feature of this
landscape and it's not obvious to me
um that the net impact of that sequence
was terrible right it may be that the
things
a these were islands they may have
actually had empty niches because
dispersal prevents certain things from
getting to the island so maybe that
there's no huge downside in terms of
some creature that was eliminated by
either the rabbits or the fox i've never
heard the analysis of what the rabbit's
displaced right i don't know the ants i
don't know that it is known or if if in
fact it's possible they did not displace
right they may not have right there are
just simply things missing from those
islands which we know because even the
islands don't have the same stuff on
them and they have a grab bag of
different critters so just you didn't
specify although many people will be
familiar san juan island is the
eponymous island in the san juan
archipelago which is in the far
northwest corner of the continental of
the lower 48 united united states part
of the same archipelago that
continues into canada which is called
the gulf islands and which also includes
the massive island that is vancouver
island right
um and they are a lovely place and i
think foxes are only on san juan island
um i believe that's right but in any
case the point is
you can be damn sure biologically
speaking at least on the mainland if you
introduce a critter it comes of the cost
to other critters it may drive them to
extinction it may compete with them in
some way that uh reduces you know
reduces their niche size
it's not always a tragedy but you're
rolling the dice every time you do that
um
and the problem is that many things that
seem very normal even some things that
we now worry will go extinct
came that way right like our honeybees
our honeybees are asian right they're
not supposed to be here um
they're now so thoroughly naturalized
and so long ago that we took asian yeah
asian honeybees in fact i didn't tell
you this i i wish i had the video handy
in fact i may send it zac and see if
he'll he can show it i was
um our our cars got absolutely
devastated by the pollen that came off
the trees uh in the last few weeks and i
took the car to the car wash yes as i
got out of the car wash
i was at the intersection just leaving
and the honeybee i think they were
honeybees were swarming
thousands of them
i've never seen anything like it really
and with no explanation i think it must
have been somebody's hive had escaped
i've heard that this happens if you
raise honeybees that a swarm can
take off on you and it can go somewhere
um but anyway it was a very
i was glad the windows were up
none of this makes any sense but i can
prove it because
you could you could prove that you found
yourself in a swarm of honeybees yes in
late april in portland can't prove the
rest of it but uh i can prove that much
um
say what
it was above above interstate five i'm
not sure why that's relevant so i i'm
sure we want to be doing this right now
or i don't know probably not but uh uh
anyway so let's let's let's finish out
this theme the the point really is this
is a
beautiful
planet
full of the most glorious stuff
and
i don't care if you think mars is a good
idea i don't care if you think we're
gonna
you know cross the galaxy and find cool
amazing other places this is always
going to be our best bet and it ain't
forever humanity will ultimately go
extinct and the planet will ultimately
fail but it is so insane to allow a
planet that is this marvelous to be
degraded
so rapidly that an individual can detect
it over the course of a small fraction
of their life that is an amazing rate of
devastation indeed and um
you know it can't be defended and i i
guess i i guess i feel like
you know because we are in the fraction
of a small fraction of people who are
lucky enough to be able to go
to some of these places that we have
some
uh
rather profound obligation to convey
both the marvelousness of it and the
tragedy so that uh
you know both can be seen
in parallax indeed i agree
um
i'm just going to finish with one
sentence
from this paper yarlot at all 2021
called quantifying production rates and
size fractions of parrotfish derived
sediment a key functional role on
maldivian coral reefs so this is not the
caribbean the maldives are in the indian
ocean
south of india
um
but this this
yes it's in science language but uh this
struck me because one of the things that
we were doing one of the things that i
wrote about in my sub stack this week
was really trying to figure out like
where are these islands from like what
what made these islands right and so
these authors yell at it all
in the journal excuse me in the journal
ecology and evolution
write reef sediment production can
result from physical
mechanical disturbance by waves and
storms and chemical ood formation as
well as biological
scraping excavating etching boring and
endogenous production by reef organisms
processes
that's just a perfect encapsulation so
we've got physical chemical and
biological methods by which landform is
created in these low-lying islands
and
reef sediment production in particular
and the
you know i i doubt this is an actually
complete complete list but it's it's a
really nice categorization scheme and
sort of the the kind of kind of way of
thinking about it that
we were trying to derive from our own
heads while we were down there and
i decided not to pursue anything in the
literature until after i published this
thing um
on subset basically to demonstrate like
look you can you can end up knowing a
lot and you may not end up knowing
everything that humans know if you rely
on your own brain and the brains of
others and you don't google it
but you will end up being better
equipped to try to figure things out in
the future if you try to figure it out
for yourself or with other people as
opposed to using your fingers to
uh to google it
yeah and in fact this is th this
particular
um
archipelago
is the exuma symbol
is a marvelous example of just uh
how complex these explanations are
because even just a brief snapshot as
soon as you realize that the sand
um isn't really
rock
right the sand is coral skeleton ground
up by fish in pursuit of algae
and the sand moves around based on the
currents and therefore it can accumulate
in places
and where it accumulates and it could
become shallow enough you have these
plants that are basically putting a toe
in the water and they're marching
they're accumulating mangroves yeah
they're
they're stabilizing this
biotic
mineral sediment yeah the roots trap the
mangrove roots trap the sediment right
and so you know you can sort of see how
the whole thing is sort of growing and
moving and it's only because our lives
are so short that you don't really
intuit that it's a little like and that
and that's the shorter term processes
right like you go back hundreds of
millions of years and you've got
the accumulation
of all you know the skeletons of all the
shelled organisms and the corals into
limestone right which is you know it's
it's compressed dead stuff yep
yeah
and uh
yeah so you have basically
some sort of fractal
uh and maybe it isn't really fractal
because the point is the longer somewhat
different processes um yeah so you get
some scale dependence um but nonetheless
you do get a very different sense it's
not like uh
you know and then god made the rocks and
then he made the critters and the
critters sit on the rocks and they make
some soil no that's not you know they're
making the landforms no and i think that
was actually one of the one of the
revelations i had down there where i was
you know we were walking around and i'm
going like
they're so low lying and i feel like i
know from past knowledge that much of
the many of the caribbean islands are
volcanic but man do these not feel
volcanic and as it turns out i think i'm
right
it's not volcanism that formed these
it's some you know much more ancient
tectonic stuff
added to an ongoing process right up
until today and tomorrow and the next
day
with regard to you know sediment
trapping by mangroves and um ancient
things
uh being with pressure and time being
turned into limestone and sandstones and
and parrotfish scraping algae off coral
and pooping it out of sand yep
extraordinary it is really marvelous
yeah
uh so
while we were down there
the mask mandates lifted for for
transportation and we flew down in masks
and when we came back to the airport
last saturday in the bahamas the airport
in the bahamas was still saying masks
required
okay well it's unfortunate
and
we um
as i was ahead of you guys on the jetway
that's the word for it right the jet way
is the walk yeah on the jet way and
there was space between me and the
people in front of me so i was sort of
all alone like walking down the jet way
and there was a stewardess ahead of me
without a mask on and we haven't
traveled much in the last years we've
traveled some and i haven't seen anyone
without a mask on a plane forever
and the people
it looked like the people who were just
disappearing around the corner in front
of me who i didn't get a good look at
still had their masks on i hadn't taken
them off but as i got closer to her i
sort of did like can i take this off
and she just beamed she was so happy she
said yes take it off we were free we
could do this and i was like awesome
like
we got someone who's actually really
enthusiastic about this and on a
different flight uh we had we had
someone who wasn't enthusiastic about it
and you know they made a point of saying
basically don't judge you know you're
allowed to judge when everyone has to
wear them but now that you don't have to
wear them don't judge everyone has their
own decisions to make like
fine i guess
but uh
i will say that i ran into
i ran into because i looked for it
this piece
that's wrong hold on zach don't don't do
this yet um
um
this piece yes now you can show
in washington post the headline for
which is justice department to appeal
mass mandate ruling if cdc says it's
needed the department said it would
defer to the cdc's assessment of health
conditions before filing any appeal
so if i may have my screen back here
there's a line in this article
that
is the abrupt end of the mandate left
little time for airports federal
agencies such as the transportation
security administration which was
charged with enforcing the mandate and
transit systems to
prepare and my first response was
are you kidding me like
little time to prepare for the lifting
of a mandate people can just take off
their masks and that's not so hard stop
mandating stop mandating it right and
then you know a couple paragraphs into
the piece they're talking about signage
and like okay sure they're gonna have to
change up the signage again like first
off just invest in a bunch of removable
stickers that say you know masks option
i'll just slap them on all the signs but
whatever i'm glad i'm not in charge of
this um but i okay signage is
kind of an issue but seriously that's
the best argument they're coming up with
well but this happened so fast
but then
as we're so we ended up with a layover
in dallas
uh and get off the plane in dallas and
no one's wearing masks of course in the
dallas airport but there's still all the
signs are up still all the signs are up
that say masks are mandatory and no
one's wearing masks because they don't
have to because the signs are out of
date
and the happy thought that i had
which may be exactly why
you know wapo on behalf of the
transportation security administration
and airports and federal agencies and
all are concerned here
is that people walking around in open
defiance of the signage
because they actually know that the
science is out of date
may make them more ash negative they
make them more likely to say hey you
know what actually i don't need to
comply this isn't compliance
is last week's news and now that i've
seen what not compliance looks like
maybe i'm more likely to resist bad
orders going forward yeah uh it's it is
a kind of a happy thought on the other
hand
obvi the whole point is we've got
captured governance right what it wants
us to do i don't want us to do right
it's up to something and i don't want to
comply on the other hand i don't want a
world of people who are not compliant i
want us to have you know
really high quality light-handed
regulation no more than is necessary to
accomplish the job and done in a way
that it is you know interferes as little
as possible with freedoms of really any
kind to leave people as free to do what
they would choose to do as possible
right that's the ideal
which means that at the point that you
have an
non-captured
government you don't want people
instinctively thinking whatever it wants
me to do i want to do the opposite you
want people thinking oh that makes sense
i'm actually reminded um maybe summer of
2020
maybe a little later than that i was in
a
text conversation with a friend of ours
from grad school who's been living in
sweden for a very long time and at that
point a lot of people were like what is
sweden doing what is going on there and
then as it turns out sweden had it had
an effective approach
and i asked our friend like what
kind of what were they thinking like it
didn't
early on when the you know the us and
the the rest of the weird world
uh were were putting really strict uh
strict
requirements in place for people sweden
was doing quite the opposite and it
seemed really not what most people who
have at least like me like a cartoon
version of what sweden might do in their
head seemed like the last thing i would
have expected them to do
and she said our friend jen said
well
uh
the people of sweden in her experience
actually really do have a good
relationship with their government
because the government does not hand
down dictates very often and the
government doesn't do that very often
such that
the goodwill of the people is so intact
that if they ever find that they have to
there will be
jennifer's um position was nearly 100
um
positive response like okay if the
government is actually telling us now
that we have to do this then then we
should do this but that's because they
reserve it that they don't they they
don't act quickly they don't act
stupidly and sure there will be mistakes
but they err on the side of
not imposing restrictions and lockdowns
and such on people they prefer that
error which preserves the goodwill of
the people and the relationship between
the people and the government to the
opposite era which is what most of the
rest of the weird world engaged in yeah
it's sort of a second order value right
that we you know we think in terms of
preventing disease or failing to prevent
disease or you know things like that but
there's this other question which is the
integrity of the system that is trying
to protect you from disease
that is actually fundamental and you
ought to move very cautiously so as to
not burn its credibility which is what
they've now done in multiple directions
by flip-flopping on everything is you
know frankly people like us have
embarrassed them into acknowledging
things or courts have forced them to
lift you know mandates they apparently
did not have the
authority to impose yep but you know if
we can connect these two things
we've got
an authoritarian
force that wants to mandate all kinds of
things it has no business mandating and
in many cases that you know even
somebody with a passing knowledge of the
facts can tell don't make any sense
right a mask mandate well if you
mandated n95 masks then maybe your
mandate is about
something epidemiological but if your
point is cover your mouth with a cloth
or whatever we now know that that
doesn't make any sense right your
mandate is not about epidemiology it's
about symbolism so
that's a horrifying abuse of authority
but we need something with authority
something that actually gives a damn
to
frankly engage in the treaty making and
the alteration of the processes that we
have in order that you know our
grandchildren can actually emerge onto a
beach and not see a sea of flotsam right
that so the point is the authority it's
not like the need for it has gone
anywhere but it's just being used for
all the wrong things indeed
um
actually i think that's a decent segue
although it won't sound like it
immediately uh to talking about a couple
things that have happened in the white
house of late so let me just start with
this is from actually a couple weeks ago
zach were you able to pull up the video
from uh the the tweet that i sent you
okay you want to show this at just about
50 seconds or so
okay so this is jen pasaki
um
here we go
this is jambasaki spinning wildly
[Laughter]
okay
that's fine um i i have the quote
that's it's fine no we're good um so
this is just a little snippet of cnn
footage from a few weeks ago i don't i
think it's early april uh and the
relevant quotation from her is
every major medical organization agrees
that gender affirming health care for
transgender kids is the best practice
and potentially life-saving
wow holy moly holy moly um that's not
true no
it may be true that every major medical
organization has stated that this is the
case right but then every major medical
organization is
wrong
and
um
we ought at this moment of all moments
in history
be able to say huh
have there been any other instances
where every major medical organization
has been wrong giving advice that was
dangerous and ridiculous and alarmist
and terrible for
huge swats of society if not the entire
society
yeah let's think let's think let's think
um
possibly at this moment
as horrifying as this is and this is why
you know the happy thought from the the
signage in the airports is maybe people
will become more ash negative maybe
people will become less compliant is at
this moment
the authorities are so
bad
at what we have been told they're trying
to do or maybe they're very very good at
what they're actually trying to do and
that seems kind of more likely
that if every major medical organization
is
agreeing about something so patently and
obviously wrong
that affirming a child's statement that
they are born in the wrong body and
therefore you should
allow them to do anything that's down
that path these incredibly invasive
fertility killing
soul-killing interventions that are
totally modern and have nothing to do
with the very few trans people that have
existed throughout history
well if every major medical organization
is advising that then really why are we
listening to them on anything
yeah i mean why are we listening to them
on any subject whatsoever if that is if
what pasaki said is true and that they
all say yes affirmative therapy
affirmative care whatever the language
is affirmative just means you say yes
when your child claims x
anything really he's a turtle he's
spider-man really no
yeah no and
were there any reality to this
whatsoever right
the fact that that is not what every
medical organization would have said ten
years ago
and
five years ago
five years passed right it's crazy okay
there are times when suddenly we all
wake up to some reality that's so well
demonstrated and important that it you
know it spreads horizontally across
society and we all come to the
realization you know that this is caused
by that or whatever
okay
if that was what happened
then there would be a result somewhere
that we could all scrutinize and we
could talk about it here on the dark
horse podcast and you would be able to
hear us evaluate whether this result
actually you know whether the experiment
was well structured whether or not the
statistics reflect the actual result
that's uh you know portrayed in in the
title and all but the point is there is
nothing this is just it's a contagious
belief that has apparently apparently
contagious belief is now what medical
advice is based on right and that is uh
a jaw-dropping recognition that that is
what we are now doing in order to figure
out how to treat
you know yes geez who is it again
children right we're now treating
children based on you know who famously
live in fantasy skips
right exactly it was the uh
the woke trans activists who made this
medical discovery which was done
so compellingly their experimentation
was so rigorous that their conclusion
could not be ignored and has now spread
into medicine that's what happened
that's what happened lived experience
experimentation
right except we can't talk about people
who transitioned and then realized they
didn't want to and transition back
that's forbidden that's somehow
transphobic you're killing them if you
do so
right so anyway i guess the point is
look there's just no there's no way to
take all of the things that would have
to be true in order for this to be
legitimate and to find them and in their
absence then the question is well then
what the hell are we doing what the hell
are we doing and how can
anyone
anyone with a straight face get up in
front of the world
and
say
what you have to do is affirm the child
no matter what they say if it has to do
with
their deep understanding of
of sex and whether or not they were born
in the wrong body as
many children don't know what it means
to be a boy or a girl
right like right well how would you i
mean of course
infants don't you know there's some
moment at which it comes to sort of dawn
on you and this is part of the reason
that there is such a
kerfuffle as minimizing it but such
such an important discussion that is
being had around you know sex ed for
kindergarten through third graders like
no
no actually because
it's it's too young
because children shouldn't be exposed to
that then well it's also
um sleight of hand in the following
sense right
now as we've said every time we've
talked about this there are trans people
we should treat them with respect they
are deserving of respect it's not an
easy easy path to follow
well in order to treat them with respect
surely we're going to have to educate
the kids that there are such people
right and then what we're going to do is
we're going to say to small children who
have no way to calibrate what we're
saying you know some people are born in
the wrong body right and children are
going to think i wonder if i was born in
the wrong body a thought that might not
have occurred to them otherwise right
it's a little bit like if i said you
know if i took a three-year-old
five-year-old a seven-year-old and i
said you know
some people
are colorblind and see the world
differently than you do or maybe you are
one of them right then the question is
instantly gee i wonder if i see the same
colors as everyone else and how would i
know and doesn't that lead to a deep
philosophical question how does one know
if my yellow is your yellow you know
this kind of thing the point is that
questioning is totally normal and what
is it spurred by it's spurred by adults
saying weird things to you like you know
some people are born in the wrong body
right which is just
so anyway the point is
the
the thin end of the wedge is
in order to protect some among us who we
all agree deserve protection
we have to be sensitive to the fact that
they exist so then we're going to tell
children that they exist and we're not
going to give them a sense of just how
rare it is because of course if you say
it's rare then maybe the lesson of you
should treat these people with respect
won't stick so you have to pretend it's
very very common right and once you
pretend it is very very common the child
can't help but wonder and then you're
you know you're uh in some sort of
medical malpractice situation if you
fail to validate the children one the
child wondering one day on the basis of
what you told them that they too might
be born in the wrong body now when i um
i made this argument here a while back
and then i also wrote about it on my sub
stack i'll
put it in the show notes um you know
which error do we prefer to make
right which of the two types of arrows
do we prefer to make do we prefer
uh to make sure
that no
actual trans person has ever been
delayed in their ability to transition
which would cause them to be somewhat
less good at passing as the opposite sex
as an adult
recognizing that trans people are
exceedingly rare
or
do we prefer
not to allow legions of children
to potentially get and actually get
fertility stopping
soul killing puberty blockers and
cross-sex hormones and in the worst
cases surgery
that will change them forever
from which they can never
fully come back
which of these things do we prefer
we prefer zero it will be the you know
will be the answer of the unnuanced
uncritical illogical people on the you
know trans activist side well of course
we can't have any of these mistakes
sorry
no you live in a land of trade-offs
there's no escaping them you have to
have one or the other of these errors
that you slightly prefer to make and i
know which one i prefer to make yeah i
prefer not to put
all the children who aren't trans at
risk which is the vast majority of them
right and
the irony is that you can tell
that this is
part of the epidemic of sophistry
from the fact that we are having to make
an argument that is really as basic as
you know what
being a parent isn't simple but this is
the job is figuring what is in your
child's interest because they can't do
it yet yeah they don't know and it's
becoming so much harder for parents i
mean gosh
the stories i hear from people and i
i don't even i haven't even responded to
everyone at this point and i just don't
even know what to say but the but the
parents who i hear from who have their
children coming to them and declaring
that they are the opposite sex and these
are parents who know what's what and
they know their kids
and they're not transphobes and they're
not bigots they're not nazis and they're
none of those things these are good
honest people who love their children
deeply and they are fighting against the
current that is coming at these children
in the schools in the media and in the
everything and in the doctor's office
and in the doctor's office from the
health care professionals from the
so-called educators from the so-called
healthcare professionals and the
so-called educators and from the
so-called journalists yeah all of whom
are doing a propaganda job and it's
destroying children and how dare they
right and why you know
let's put it this way
there is a reason that
at least until five minutes ago and for
some of us continuing right through this
very instant we detest pedophiles right
there's a reason and it is because they
are
a threat to children they will destroy
the lives of children if they are
allowed to do what they want to do right
and so the point is okay we have certain
rights right if somebody
is trying to molest your child
you have actually extraordinary rights
to protect that child
if the somebody who's trying to destroy
your child is a confused teacher
or doctor or
bureaucrat
you have no such rights because what
they're telling you is that actually we
are acting in your child's interest and
you've lost track of what it is
and we may in fact
take your parental rights right and you
know we are marching ever further in
that direction so
again it's like look
at what point do you hear yourself
trying struggling to make an argument
that actually these people don't have
the right to interfere with my child's
future fertility
right why why am i even having to make
that argument why would i ever have to
make that argument isn't that
self-evident maybe
it's the sophistry maybe the sophistry
has gotten to this topic too right i
think right and so i guess that's what i
want is i want just like a
an emblem a flag something i can hold up
at the point that the sophistry has
reached the next argument i don't want
to have to argue it again i just want to
say ah it's happened again
the contagion has gotten here as well
darn sophistry foul yep i can't imagine
that we're going to solve this in
english now because the sophists have
arrived you know that that sort of thing
yep all right we're gonna have to work
something up for that okay
uh you want to talk about um
elon twitter lefty meltdown
by administration
department of homeland security those
are the key words i have written down
here i'll try i'll try to streamline a
little bit because uh we're pretty
deeply into this we really are yeah it's
late now it's dinner time hour um let's
just say it has been very dinner time
for everyone listening live unless
you're in hawaii or australia
it has been very interesting to watch uh
elon so far do exactly what he suggested
he was gonna do apparently for the
reason that he suggested he was gonna do
it and to watch
uh
all of the people on the blue team
freak the [ __ ] out about this guy who
actually figured out how to put electric
cars on the road in a way that we are
all encountering them and driving them
and
charging them and all of the things that
we do i mean right it's like
how dare he
it's not the most
hitlerian move i've ever seen right i
think he's just really bad at it yeah we
have to be on the lookout for
hitler's that are bad at it as well
crypto hitlers um
yeah and you know hitler wasn't a subtle
guy so no
in any case it's very interesting to
watch people freak out and project all
kinds of things onto this which you know
i admit it could just be a business
thing but i really don't think this is
just a business thing i think elon who
frankly is a user of twitter more than
most of us right actually has innovated
his own mechanism he's pushed the limits
of edge lording and whatever it is that
he does on twitter and he's done it
artfully he actually likes the place and
frankly i think he's just pissed off on
a lot of our behalf and the behalf of
many of the departed and you know
by whom i mean megan murphy and um
but anyway
so far
i i'm enjoying watching elon do what
elon said elon was going to do and watch
it turn the world inside out i think
that's that's a pretty good stuff but at
the same time you watch the other side
on the march and it's actually quite
revealing of what they've been about and
what we've you know inferred that they
are about from their behavior over the
last several years
right so we have you know uh the white
house making noises about finally doing
something about section 230 right you
know as elon is threatening to create a
free speech platform the white house is
threatening to make platforms
responsible for the content that their
users put on and things like this so
that's an interesting
maneuver
and also at the same time we find the
federal government the department of
homeland security the biden
administration appointing a
disinformation czar
right it's like
they did everything except label at the
ministry for truth right they did
everything it's the same idea right it's
it's obviously and you know intended to
shape
uh discourse not to purify it of
of incorrect
ideas which is impossible of course but
it is clearly designed
to police those of us who would dare
critique the official narrative right
and in fact even their staffing of the
thing right the person they put in
charge whose name hey zach could you put
up the article on hand here
um
all right could you put it where we can
read it
yeah here we go um
yeah scroll down a little bit all right
so you want to read a couple paragraphs
here you want me to start yeah just okay
is team biden no longer even trying to
avoid being a laughingstock wait what am
i reading oh this is the new york post
new york post okay is team biden no
longer even trying to avoid being a
laughingstock why did biden just appoint
a champion of the hunter biden laptop
cover-up to serve as chief of his new
ministry of truth department of homeland
security alejandro mayorkas probably
butchering that name i apologize
announced that his agency is creating a
quote disinformation governance board
given the biden record it is unclear
whether the new board will be fighting
or promulgating disinformation
nina jankowitz the head of the new board
is a bryn mawr graduate who worked for
the national democratic institute which
is heavily funded by the national
endowment for democracy which spurred
perennial controversy for interfering in
foreign elections
all right so here we have somebody who
has
um
we're back uh here we have somebody who
has um
promulgated
actual disinformation who has advanced
the idea that hunter biden's laptop was
the result of a russian disinformation
campaign
rather than the result of a drug addict
stupidly leaving his laptop at a repair
shop and
it's embarrassing and illegal content
spilling into the world right so is this
person really in a position to tell
anybody what is and is not
uh disinformation what's more
the agency in question the dhs the dhs
has defined mal information which we
have mocked here on this very channel
mal information being things that are
based in truth that make you distrust
your government right so do we want or
that are bad for the other messaging of
the government right it is uh well and
the point is it's terrorism mal
information that is things that are
based in truth that cause you to
distrust your government that is a form
of terrorism according to the dhs which
has now this new disinformation
controlling branch headed by this person
who has promoted at least
incorrect ideas
and the fact is
during the election
uh all right the presidential election
of 2020. the 2020 presidential election
okay um i actually was very concerned
about hunter biden's laptop and i was
very concerned about twitter
um
throwing the new york new york post off
for
uh
for reporting on the story right a story
which turned out to be true in the end
um i was also very concerned about the
state of mental decline of our president
right and i was our now president our
now president and i was told on both of
these fronts that um
this was some kind of disinformation
right that we were being manipulated by
some force that wanted us to believe
that biden was compromised both
as a matter of corruption and as a
matter of mental decline
and
you know it hasn't taken long and i will
remind people i've been very good at
predicting things one of the things i
got really really really wrong
was i predicted that biden would not
actually take office and the reason i
predicted that as i think i mentioned
last week
is that i did not believe
that the democratic party could be so
stupid and so craven as to allow
somebody in this obvious state of
decline to take this office in which he
would have for example control over
our nuclear arsenal right
in which he would be you know for
example in a position to manage a
pandemic right the idea of taking
somebody
who is experiencing obvious senility and
putting them in such a role is
insane and i didn't think even the
democrats were up to it and yet
apparently they are
um
and so actually on that second point
zach do you want to put up that uh video
on i sent you
got that video
do you want to say some things while
he's doing that here we go
we're going to seize their yachts their
luxury homes and other ill-begotten
gains
of putin's kleptocracy
yeah
kleptocracy and clip the guys who are
the kleptocracies
did you get through it we're going to
seize their yachts
all right another
which you and i could not hear as i was
having it played the president stumbles
through
a
uh statement about effectively some
bluster about going after um putin and
the other kleptocrats uh in russia
there are
multiple errors and he never comes up
with the term uh kleptocracy or he does
come up with it but can't re can't
figure out that it's the right word to
place in the sentence no dad had it
stolen from him
probably yeah um
but
all right
we're stuck in one of two unacceptable
worlds
we are either in a world where
um
we have a
nuclear nation having invaded its
neighbor
right
um
in which nuclear weapons could be in
play and president biden in this
confused compromised state of mental
decline might actually be in charge of
whether or not we respond to
something that shows up on norad's radar
with uh you know
nuclear retaliation or maybe something
that would show up on their radar would
be a mistake and president biden would
take somebody too seriously who thought
it was real who knows the point is
it would be the height of insanity to
take a nation with weaponry as ferocious
as ours and to put it in the hands of
somebody who
is obviously obviously in decline and my
point further would be he's obviously in
decline now some of us could detect it
during the election we weren't guessing
it was apparent then
and what that means is if we can all see
it now
the people who were in charge of his
candidacy saw it then and they allowed
this to happen anyway so here are the
two worlds we live in either
that guy in that state is in charge of
our nuclear arsenal and also in charge
of whether or not to create a ministry
of truth
right is that who decided to make the
ministry of truth or do we believe that
he understands the implications of such
a thing or here's the other universe we
might be living in
maybe he's not really in charge right
and maybe yes they're losing control of
his ability to deliver a long enough
speech that he's not an embarrassment to
himself and to the country
but then who is in charge right now
we've got a question of has is this a
coup
right is somebody who's actually
mentally competent in charge of all the
things you would want a mentally
competent person to be in charge of in
which case who is it right
accountability our entire structure our
governmental
constitutional structure depends on our
knowing who it is right it has to this
this can't be some unelected nameless
person behind the scenes so transparency
is paramount right i guess my point
would be neither of these things is the
least bit acceptable and this did not
happen by accident it wasn't invisible
in fact the very fact that
his mental decline was not widely widely
discussed on all sides during the
election had to do with the intimidation
of people who did discuss it i was one
of them i remember what happened when
you talked about it
so you know do we really want a ministry
of truth uh
deciding who gets to say what and acting
on the basis that it believes that to
say things that are out of step with
this mainstream narrative might be
terrorism i mean this is all sounding
quite dystopian and i don't think one
has to be particularly imaginative to
see it
i agree
so i guess that means
even though it is the case
that if you were to list
all americans
and you were to rank order them in terms
of how much i want to see them as
president
kamal harris would be
way down at the bottom of that list
not at the very bottom no no no no there
are people i want to see less than
kamala harris but not a lot of them
that's what i'm saying right nonetheless
you've been in downtown portland lately
because
i hear you
i hear you it's tough but here's here's
the here's how bad this is okay as much
as i do not trust kamal harris yep right
the fact of having somebody who has lost
his mental faculties in a position
that's important is so dangerous
it's so dangerous that i believe
actually the right thing we should all
agree on it is sheen you know
kamala harris 2022 that's my point
2022
yeah
as if it's a campaign
well
i guess you know
i think i just lost the plot i think
okay yeah i think the point is
we have allowed
um maniacs to mismanage our system so
badly
that the only rational course of action
is for kamal harris to ascend to the
presidency
and
um and i don't you know let's put it
this way you don't know
on what day the generals are going to
wake up the president and say look let
me explain to you what the situation is
we have 15 minutes to figure out what to
do next right you don't know when that's
going to happen
we can't afford any
nights in which the president is going
to be awoken to answer a question as
serious as do we launch nuclear weapons
and have it be joe biden in his current
condition
well but i mean your your two worlds
question that you began with uh suggests
strongly that we're not living in that
world right that we're not living in the
world in which uh the current
president by name is the one who would
be asked okay if that's the case though
then
how frightening is it for us to have
just discovered that our nuclear arsenal
is in the hands of somebody whose name
we do not know very
i mean
i just don't you know yeah but i i guess
the point is if that's true i'm still
for kamala harris because actually you
know the uh the line of succession goes
through her next and so
in order for there to be a nation that
makes any sense at all based on the art
it has to be her no matter how briefly
right exactly
and hopefully it would be very brief yep
okay can we just talk briefly about um
human footprints in giant sloth
footprints
i was hoping you would raise this issue
yeah okay you wanna you wanna lead i do
wanna lead but i don't know anything
about this story and so i'm not in a
good position to do it yeah just two two
very very brief i mean we're we're
closing in on two hours here and i gotta
get on plane tomorrow so like we're
gonna we're gonna close this up here um
are you wearing your mask on the plane
yeah or right now no no yeah it's it's a
it's a very fancy mask that you can't
see it's it's uh but uh
yeah no i'm not wearing my mask no i was
talking about your snorkeling mask oh
and the plane yeah
i think that's the way to confront those
mandates to confuse them yeah totally
covers my nose my eyes you didn't say
what kind of a mask
yeah um
okay just two two news stories from
science uh this week not you can put on
my screen if you like zach neither of
these were
published
thank you in the journal science but
science does a thing where it sort of
it scrapes other scientific journals and
finds the stories it finds most
interesting so here we have ancient
human playground found inside sloth
footprints
fossilized tracks of a giant ground
sloth are stamped with tiny human feet
whoa i know so that's kind of the story
like that's all that's so anyway let me
see if i've got this so giant ground
sloth which i have to tell you is a
creature i've been fascinated with since
i was a kid yeah because they used to be
you know la brea tarpons i grew up right
near there and giant sloth was yeah one
of the one of the creatures
um
so
what i'm confused by is the term fossil
um should be sub fossil
i'm not sure
pr probably and actually i really don't
know much can you give me my screen back
here zach
let me see this is uh
it's still unpublished work
the slightly newer the slightly more
expansive version
um says eleven thousand five hundred
years ago
so that's sub fossil yeah indeed
so the distinction
we're puzzling over it is um
fossils are
mineralized
replacements for bone so if you have a
bone that gets buried in some sediment
then over a very long period of time the
actual bone disappears and it is
replaced by something in the shape of
that bone that is basically a rock
in the case of things very similar to
what
limestone oh maybe not no there's not
replacement there never mind but uh in
the case of
somebody who died 15 000 years ago and
fell into a tar pit there's not been
nearly enough time for that replacement
so what you get is actual bone and
things like that so in this case it's
you know it's neither it's footprints
but the period of time is short enough
that bone would not have been replaced
so yeah
but anyway the the
the story is here's a little glimpse
into the ways that uh 11 500 years ago
in new mexico children were playing in
the puddles left by the footprints of a
giant sloth
now here
is the question okay
were
the adults in this child's group
morally obligated to help this child
transition into a giant ground sloth
since apparently the child
as it was maneuvering through the
footprints was probably
um imagining that that he had been born
into these yeah i mean i think this is
probably the origin of the uh concept
but those are really big shoes to fill
yeah and um and then probably what came
up next was well sloths don't actually
wear shoes as far as we know
no they don't um but i i think they
could pull them off but
not so well because they don't have
thumbs no
yeah yeah
okay so that's one hello it's dinner
time for tesla um
and the second little bit of of
scientific apolitical
apolitical science story for this week
is and here again you can just show my
screen briefly zach
is
is when it comes to scorpions it's the
small ones you need to watch out for
study confirms indiana jones line bigger
scorpions are indeed less deadly
and this is based on this does come out
of a published piece of research which
uh so long as that's on my screen i
can't find for you guys but
uh
basically it's it says
it says what it says it says um and the
the paper is
just published called scorpion species
with smaller body sizes and narrower
chile have the highest venom potency
published in the journal toxins
chile being i had to look this up
pinchers or claws at the end of
appendages in arachnids or crustaceans
and
this paper has a distinction of
beginning in the abstract with the
following sentences the very first
sentence in this paper
scorpionism is a global health concern
with an estimation of over 1 million
annual envenomation cases
scorpionism scorpionism that's not the
term i would have thought scorpion isn't
mine
but yes so as as indiana jones
apparently said in one of the less
popular indiana jones movies uh it is
the smaller ones uh that deliver the
worst not bite but sting and the larger
ones are tend to be less dangerous any
analysis in there about why
uh not as far as i saw i only skimmed
the paper that was actually in toxins uh
briefly as i only found it just before
we came live here
but i
did not
see that in my in my skimming it's one
of those things i'm i'm going to guess
and if i am slandering the authors here
i apologize but this is one of these
things where a very provocative
empirical result like this will result
in very low quality adaptive speculation
on the reason some of which then gets
written into the lore as if it was a
fact like um
you know uh baby rattlesnakes
are
more deadly
because they haven't learned to control
their venom
right right rather than there's a very
good ecological reason why a smaller
rattlesnake might be more likely to
envenomate you
right which i think is far more likely
um
but anyway you know how would you even
test that they haven't learned to
control it yet
i mean it's not impossible but it's
difficult for sure you certainly can't
use a questionnaire you can uh at your
own risk
very very spotty data
um
no
i don't think it's here oh well i'm not
sure so i'm just trying to quickly again
look over the actual paper but
um
but at least
on on second quick pass i don't i don't
see it here see the adaptive explanation
all right well
um maybe that's for the best
perhaps but i'll post i'll post this
um i the lead author is in the venom
systems and proteomics lab at national
university of ireland which i think
that's great venom systems and
proteomics lab yeah it's pretty pretty
awesome you don't want to cross those
people that'd be my guess yeah no very
much so um so let me just jump right to
the bottom where they're often if
they're going to be any adaptive
explanations would be
fair um
yeah that's a lot of not finding it no
okay
all right
well
have we arrived
i think
that we have arrived so we are
not going to do a q a today we will be
back here in six days next wednesday
midday our time
uh so you know noonish pacific and we
will also not do a q a but we will be
back then four days after that
uh for our normal saturday not this
saturday but the following saturday
where we will do a q a
and
in the meantime look for there will
probably be
probably be a a guest episode of dark
horse that comes out before we're back
live streaming
i believe there will be
a guest episode that will emerge and
there may be a live stream keep your eye
out for that keep your eye out for that
so
maybe
without further ado
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside be well everyone
[Music]
[Music]
you